on yesterday's program we talked about
this Texas
Trump elector who because for religious
reasons could not bring himself to cast
an electoral vote for Donald Trump
decided to resign which will as I
mentioned yesterday lead to a
replacement elector showing up and
casting that electoral vote for Donald
Trump and I speculated you know it would
be more powerful to stay in and not vote
Trump or vote for Hillary Clinton than
to just leave and let yourself be
replaced with another Trump vote which
might make you feel better but it would
have absolutely no impact after the show
I spoke with a source of mine who I
inherently trust who told me something
that to be frank is the the scope of
this is something we've never had our
hands on before and this is someone who
is in a position to know what I'm about
to tell you and we had a conversation
about this and this is something that if
true is absolutely huge and what my
source told me is that there is a
coalition of at least 15 electors
electoral voters electors Trump electors
who have decided that they are not going
to cast their electoral votes for Donald
Trump on December 19th the other piece
of this from my source is that this
group of 15 electors is quietly
campaigning to reach out to convert
other electors to not vote Trump with
the goal of denying him the 270
electoral votes that are required to
become President of the United States
now of course the implications of this
are absolutely monstrous and this number
of 15 to refresh the data 37 is sort of
a key number with with 306 electoral
votes for Trump
Donald Trump would need to lose 37 to no
longer have enough electoral votes to be
President of the
it states this goes above and beyond the
discussions of recounts that have been
going on particularly as those are very
unlikely to change anything and if there
is going to be a flipping of this
election it's going to depend on the
electors now many people will hear this
Rachel and Pat and they will say these
electors would be doing something
fundamentally wrong if they decide to
vote for someone other than Donald Trump
or just not vote for Donald Trump I
couldn't disagree with you more
Alexander Hamilton was one of the
framers who said electors are actually
supposed to apply what Hamilton himself
referred to as quote a judicious
combination of all the reasons and
inducements which were proper to govern
their governed their choice in other
words the electors have some wisdom and
they have some ability flexibility to
say this is the way that states have
voted and I am going to consider that
along with my broader assessment of the
candidate and make a decision that I
believe is the right decision for the
country so I think anybody who's just
arguing electors should not do this
because of how the electoral college was
created go back to the framers
themselves and we've been voicing for
the past few weeks now about how Hillary
Clinton won the popular vote yet got
Robb's because Donald Trump won the
electoral college
yeah well the electoral college giveth
the electoral college can taketh away -
like they could get screwed off by the
same system now Rachel the if there is
ever a case to be made and we're talking
broadly here that an elector should
apply judgment that may lead them not to
vote for the winner of the state for
which they are an elector when you have
and will dig into this later such a
massive defeat for Donald Trump in the
popular vote there's no doubt that
mathematically electors choosing to do
something different than that which the
state voters voted for would be most
mathematically justified compared to in
other elections this is just me looking
at numbers I suppose but has there been
any historical instance where this has
changed
anything no there has it but has there
been any election like this one in
history right I mean how many things
have happened in this election that have
never happened before I would argue many
so so I don't know that the it hasn't
happened before argument is the best
argument this time around pad and there
have been faithless electors just not
enough to change the outcome of the vote
some of the faithless electors have just
been by accident and in some of these
states there are penalties for voting
against the will of the people but a lot
of the times it's just a few thousand
dollars or some sort of fine that can be
made up by someone else
yeah a thousand bucks to have what would
be arguably
a massive impact on the next 40 years of
life on earth Rachel I would take the
thousand dollar fine and you know what
there's probably people that would cover
the thousand bucks for you would be my
guess yeah I would take it too so the
and again as Pat said we've had
faithless electors in the past but not
to the degree that it flipped an
election what my source has told me is
that currently the number is 15 and that
those 15 are lobbying others the number
needs to be 37 so so that is where
things stand today I have nothing else
to say I've presented all the
information I have to you and we now
have until December 19th to figure out
what is ultimately going to happen